good morning heck it's tuesday so almost
exactly one year ago we announced a new
project to support partners in health
and the government of sierra leone in
their efforts to radically reduce
maternal mortality this initiative which
seeks to raise 25 million dollars over
five years will strengthen the health
care system in sierra leone's kono
district at
every level from hiring and training
community health workers to building
staffing and supplying a new maternal
center of excellence at coidu government
hospital which will have all the
clinical spaces and services that
mothers and their children
need to stay healthy that's everything
from a child health clinic to a neonatal
intensive care unit to family planning
clinics to labor and delivery to
operating rooms this maternal center of
excellence will dramatically change the
quality of health care available to
women and children
in kono and we hope it can provide a
blueprint to reducing maternal and child
mortality elsewhere in the world
or at least that's what i said a year
ago it has been a very
long year and today i would like to give
you an update on where we are
first though i want to recommend the
documentary bending the arc which is
currently available on netflix and which
explores how when the global health
community believed that treating
multi-drug resistant tuberculosis in
impoverished countries was impossible
partners in health helped prove
otherwise because i think it's helpful
background in understanding why partners
in health is now working to show that
maternal and child mortality
can be radically reduced starting in a
place with one of the world's highest
rates of these unnecessary deaths
one out of every 20 women in sierra
leone can expect to die
in pregnancy or childbirth and almost
all of those deaths would be preventable
with a strong health care system
every day women die for want of a safe
emergency c-section or for want of a
blood transfusion or for want of blood
pressure medication
basic services and medicines that most
of us living in rich countries take for
granted
and we know this is not like inevitable
or natural in part because as the sierra
leonean healthcare system has begun to
strengthen over the last few years there
have been big reductions in child and
maternal mortality like at the hugely
successful well body clinic that pih
runs there hasn't been a single maternal
death in
years the change is happening we just
believe it needs to be
accelerated by a high quality teaching
hospital that makes pregnancy and
childbirth safer for both mother and
child
so where are we well the original plan
was to break ground on the maternal
center of excellence in april of 2021
but with covid and everything the plan
is still to break ground in april of
2021 which is a wonderful credit to both
partners in health and the government of
sierra leone and some system
strengthening is already happening more
community outreach more
training for nurses and midwives social
support programs for pregnant women and
new moms and other maternal health
initiatives
but recently when i spoke to isa
dumbayah the nurse who leads coyote
government hospitals maternal and child
health teams she said the next big step
for the community
is the maternal center of excellence
special care baby units we have a new
unit where new space that we've just
moved the babies to the results already
in three months are phenomenal
but yesterday i went in there and it was
full which is
why the maternal center of excellence
cannot come
soon enough this is a space and place
where women
in sierra leone would know for the first
time
that they are worthy of having the same
level of care
the same treatments the same access to
equipment as
anybody else in any part of the world
the design for the maternal center of
excellence created in partnership and
consultation with the staff at the
hospital
and the community it serves is really
wonderful
it features lots of locally sourced
materials like the community is
especially enthusiastic about the use of
stones cast off from the nearby diamond
mine to help build the hospital that
mine has become a symbol of destruction
and despair for many in kono but
now stones from that mine can become a
symbol of hope and of course it'll have
all the stuff a hospital needs 24-hour
electricity
safe and sanitary operating rooms and
extensive blood bank incubators for the
nicu
and so on all resources the coitu
government hospital
never had even just a few years ago it's
hard to overstate how
big the change will be like the mcoe
will almost triple the number of
maternal hospital beds in the region
they expect to see over 4 000 deliveries
a year
a five-fold increase in the number of
family planning visits and
critically the mcoe will dramatically
increase the number of medically
necessary c-sections that can be
performed
and because it's a teaching hospital the
mcoe will help train the next generation
of sierra leonean healthcare workers
from doctors to nurses to community
health workers
right so the overall five-year cost of
this project is 25 million dollars but
in order to break ground we need to
raise 20 million
this is because both pih and the
government of sierra leone want to
prevent a building getting like halfway
built and then abandoned or
fully built but never adequately staffed
or supplied which is a huge
problem in impoverished countries too
often people or institutions make big
promises that they fail to keep or make
short-term investments that are quickly
abandoned and none of that
strengthens the system in the long run
and so that's why we have to raise 20
million dollars before breaking ground
because
thousands of you have become monthly
donors to this project at pih.org
hank and john and because incredibly
generous matching donors from within
nerdfighteria have banded together to
match
every monthly donation at the current
rates of donation
over five years we will have raised over
million dollars another 3.5 million
dollars has come from large donors to
pih
thank you if you want a fuller more
detailed breakdown of the fundraising so
far there is a link to a video in the
doobly-doo and the comments below but
yeah
all together we have raised over 18.5
million dollars
in the last 13 years nerdfighteria has
accomplished some amazing things but
that has to be the most amazing and i
know how grateful all of our pih friends
in sierra leone are to you all but
there is still a funding gap like one
way of looking at this is that we have
raised 93 percent of the money we need
to break ground and another way of
looking at it is that we still
have a million and a half dollars left
to raise
which is a lot of money i expected that
because of the pandemic and the
tremendous stresses it has caused that
donations might go down
but in fact they have gone up every
month and i find that so encouraging
and of course we understand that many of
you are not in a position to donate
right now and
that is okay but if you are able to
become a monthly donor at pih.org
hank and john it can make a huge
difference
i have seen how critical the need is for
better child and maternal health care in
kono it is an emergency it's just one
that doesn't make headlines
also in order to get to the 20 million
mark we are gonna need some
larger donations so if you happen to be
in a position to donate say
five thousand dollars or more to this
project there is a separate link in the
doobly-doo below or you can email me
at sparksflyop gmail.com to learn more i
want to emphasize one thing though the
mcoe will be
like all of coitu government hospital
owned by the people of sierra leone
through their government and it will be
staffed almost entirely by sierra leone
healthcare workers
and supported and funded to a large
degree by the government of sierra leone
the heroes of this story are the people
like isita who sacrifice
so much to help vulnerable women deliver
safely
hank i said earlier that one in 20 women
in sierra leone can expect to die in
pregnancy or childbirth
not long ago that statistic was one in
17 women and so maternal death is
declining and the progress
is real it's just not fast enough every
healthcare worker i've spoken to in
sierra leone has gut-wrenching stories
about the pain of knowing what needs to
be done to save the life of a mother or
a child but being unable to do so
because there is no working ambulance or
there is no blood bank or there is no
safe operating room
as one piher told me we know how to save
women's lives
we just need the tools and that is our
challenge and our
opportunity to help provide the tools to
this community so that they can
radically reduce maternal and child
mortality so again if you can join us in
donating the link is pih.org
hank and john to the thousands of you
who are already monthly donors
thank you we are 93 of the way there
and if you can't donate thank you for
your attention
it matters if the world was paying
attention to this crisis
more would be done to stop it so thank
you
and hank i will see you on friday